cyberpunk gets the special edition Xbox
1x there are some sequel details teased
about modern warfare and fortnight is
hosting another concert
I'm Lucy and welcome to a check point
for Monday 4/20 happy anniversary god of
war first up cyberpunk may be coming in
September but you can get yourself ready
for it with a brand new limited edition
Xbox 1x console and yes it's
breathtaking Microsoft revealed that the
console will be limited to 45,000 units
and it'll go on sale in June but if you
want to inject some cyberpunk into your
veins a little earlier you can grab the
accessories from today including a
controller Xbox pro charging stand two
different Seagate game drives and a
steel series headset according to major
Nelson's blog this will be the last
limited edition console for the Xbox one
X so it's time to take a trip down
memory lane which were your favorites
the card one gears my personal favorites
the Taco Bell cuz I actually have that
one let me know in the comments below if
you played last year's modern warfare
reboot you may have been surprised to
see one of its characters appear as an
operator in its multiplayer campaign we
last saw Alex preparing to sacrifice
himself to explode a facility so his
appearance of the multiplayer may seem
like it's Infinity Ward trying to tie up
loose ends a Twitter user suggested to
Infinity Ward's narrative director that
Alex's story may best be served in a
full blown sequel to which Taylor
applied who says we won't this isn't the
first time a sequel has been teased with
Taylor previously tweeting that Alex's
appearance in the game's multiplayer
wasn't stealing story beats from what
comes next from Modern Warfare quotes
there's plenty of ground left for
sequels System Shock 3 was announced in
2015 but it's had a rocky development
and its future is looking vague
publishers Starbreeze relinquished the
rights to distribute in the game last
year but developer other side said it
would continue making the game however
earlier this year it was suggested by
layoffs at the studio and reports from
former employees that the game had been
cancelled
Walter samel finally released a
statement on the studio's forums we're
still here we're all working remotely
right
probably like most of you our new
concept is coming along nicely and we
are really excited about it we have a
cool and we think distinctive art style
for it and we have that and gameplay
coming together in Unreal Engine 4 I
know it's a tease but I just can't
really say anything about it at this
point
it's not entirely clear what their new
concept may be or how it relates to
System Shock 3 but the dream is not
entirely dead if you're missing going to
see live music and God knows I am then
try booting up fortnight rapper Travis
Scott is taking to the battle royale to
launch a new song in the games
astronomical event which will run at 5
specific times between April 23rd to
25th we've got the full list on site if
you don't want to miss out by joining of
these specific times you can experience
the new song and get some new fortnight
loot including two new loading screens
and a new glider plus they'll be new
challenges
so that's Travis Scott marshmallow Star
Wars where's my Nine Inch Nails hold on
t buts it's been a long as 17 years
since the last Dino Crisis game but if
you're feeling the itch there's a new
mod for Resident Evil 3 that's just for
you it turns the shuffling undead into
dinosaurs admittedly there's only one
type of dinosaur right now which looks
like a mini t-rex but with a massive
head anyway
Dino evil 3 is a super cool mod but it's
still very much in its early stages
sometimes the dinosaurs get stuck in
rooms and nemesis is nowhere to be found
but you know what they say life or in
this case modders finds a way that's it
from Monday April 20th for all the
latest keep at GameSpot and I'm on
twitter at Lucy James games I'll see you
next time